ich habe bestimmt schon in über 2 300
verschiedenen burger restaurants und
burger gegessen
in ganz europa etwas gedacht und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
ja halt ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
kurz den anfang mache ich mit dem stativ
also julias blatt nicht da aber der wird
gleich dazu kommen ich habe aber gesagt
zu ihr ich starte jetzt schon mal weil
wir haben wir schon relativ spät und
sonst machen die nachher zu einer woche
kam ein video beziehungsweise eigentlich
eine neue kleine format idee von mir
und zwar habe ich ja früher schon öfter
mal so sachen bestellt und auch
restaurants getestet und so und ich habe
auf lieferando einige neue restaurants
gefunden wie zb 0,0 bewertungen haben
also da hat noch niemand irgendwie einer
bewertung schrieben werten beim letzten
mal schon irgendwie so eine pizzeria da
war ich dann halt der erste der das
bewerben konnte habe ich dann auch
gemacht und in dem video auch schon
gesagt dass es noch einen burger laden
gibt der auch nicht bewertet ist also da
keine bewertung hat und viele von euch
wissen sie eigentlich ich bin burger
gibt aber sag ich mal durch war ich kann
also bürger sind schon echt geil wenn
sie dann lecker sind
ich habe bestimmt schon in über 2 300
verschiedenen burger restaurants einen
burger gegessen
in ganz europa da wenn ja auch ein
bisschen schleusenbrücke feierlich vom
thema ab aber ich kann mich mit bürgern
eigentlich aus und ich bin auch immer
sehr enttäuscht dann wenn ein bürger
nicht gut schmeckt oder wenn die iren
den restaurant burger verkauft die aber
gar kein bürger können gut deswegen habe
ich mir diesen bürgerladen herausgesucht
und da bestellen wir jetzt mal ich kann
den namen eigentlich nennen bamberger
heißt das hört sich eigentlich ganz cool
also bamberger gibt schlimmeres alle
leute hier jemand sehen bamberger 0
bewertungen durchgehend geöffnet alles
klar
na gut gut und das ist auch schon die
speisekarte ich glaub ja dann
mindestbestellwert von 12 euro das heißt
ich bestellen und burger pommes und
getränke eigentlich nicht schauen wir
mal
vielleicht haben die ja auch irgendwas
ausgefallen das was einmal testen könnte
jetzt ein ganz normaler cheeseburger
eigentlich
sitzt ein bisschen lernen ich habe hier
gerade schon gesehen welch supreme
burger mit bacon dreifach leserbrief
salat tomaten zwiebeln mayonnaise und
warmer spezial war spezialist eventuell
auch mit soße keine ahnung
das finde ich schon mal cool ich tu's
mich fügt man hinzu wenn es schon sieben
euro
ok pommes natürlich auch super wichtig
das haben wir hier noch da biste prix
mit 4fach käse doppeltief war das ist so
also für mich persönlich da ein burger
eine maximal 160 gramm fleisch haben
alles darüber ist dann also fleißig so
und das fleisch muss natürlich auch gut
sein wenn es über diesen 160 gramm ist
und das fleisch trotzdem sehr gut ist
ist es in ordnung finde ich allerdings
leidet dann dieser burger geschmack
darunter alle dieses gesamtpakets finde
ich wenn zu viel fleisch drauf ist
deswegen meiner meinung nach immer
maximal 160 gramm am besten sogar noch
ein bisschen weniger direkte kritik alex
genau da müsste vor ihm hatten wir
gerade david beckham supreme nation
bürgern mit käse bis salaten nachos fu
nehme ich das auch noch mit das hier ist
dann wahrscheinlich was vegetarisches
genauer burger und hier sind pommes ja
ganz normale comics für 250 ja kommen
chili cheese tipp noch dazu und ein
getränk brauche ich gar nicht so das ist
ja hat ja nichts mit dem restaurant zu
tun das machen jährlich selber das war
es doch schon also wir haben eigentlich
eine ziemlich kurz und knapp gehaltene
speisekarte allerdings reicht es völlig
aus vielleicht hätte man noch ein
bisschen mehr saucen ergänzen können so
also die meisten bürger leben hier in
köln kommen auf jeden fall deutlich
größere auswahl an süßen ich habe auch
eben mal gegoogelt
das ist wirklich ein reiner
lieferservice also das ist kein
restaurant was läge da existiert
anscheinend also habe ich zumindest
nicht gefunden
ich weiß nicht ob ich das jetzt so gut
finden soll weil er ahnt dass
restaurants kann natürlich
so ein bisschen auf die hygiene schauen
ja aber gut ich würde sagen bestellen
das mal 18 europa brauche ich diese
nation burger ich will ja auch mal so
wenig wie möglich menschen meisten
deswegen nehme ich den mal besser raus
ich weiß es nicht jugend schon vergessen
vor allem eigentlich so ein bürger mit
run up n news und guacamole ich glaube
den mag ich nicht auch wenn der jetzt
wirklich geil gemacht wer mit guten
zutaten aber ich bin halt kein fan von
cala pi news und guacamole so deswegen
nehme ich den mal vorsichtig raus und
dann haben wir aus dem becken supreme
burger ach so scheiße jetzt brauche noch
zwei euro kann man eine cola muss dann
auch sein bestellen
das hat direkte klappt ja das können
doch schnell und meine 55 minuten ein ja
gut ich melde mich wenn es da ist vielen
dank für deine bestellung jetzt habe ich
gerade auch schon die male bekommen und
dann bin ich mal gespannt ob das
eventuellen restaurant wird oder ein
lieferservice bei der milch in zukunft
öfter bestellen werde und der sich über
eine wette erste positive bewertungen
freuen darf wir haben es jetzt hier
bekommen also dass es einst tat kam
richtig pünktlich eigentlich auf die
minute 550 lieferzeit also leider nicht
schneller aber gut war halt auch so
vorhergesagt und company nahm alex wie
das war angegeben gut also wir haben
bestellt chili cheese lose chili mangos
lohse
das sieht ja schon mal ganz gut aus und
hier haben wir das essen heute
ich wollte eigentlich zwei bürger
bestellen aber ich dachte das wird
wahrscheinlich zu viel ich habe ich
nicht deswegen habe ich nur einen
aber das ist so wie diese leute sind die
labbrig man sieht irgendwie schon direkt
auf den ersten blick oder dass das keine
guten kommen das halte ich noch mal hoch
wie sie das sind so thomas so schlechte
sportplatz kommen jetzt weißt du dich
daran gegen den fußball
neben dem fußballspiel christof demuth
und das hier ist der burger es ist ein
burger lieferdienste ok also die machen
nur vage nicht pizza pasta berger nushi
und so also nur berger
[Musik]
es riecht eigentlich tut gut
ok wat ich wohl mal kurz den keller man
muss aber sagen new york hat und richtig
richtig guten ausdruck von der geben und
wieder das ist wie also sonst standard
denken was jeder machen kann was wenn
wir jetzt hier einkaufen mir und sagen
hey das mal bürger battle machen kommt
so was dabei raus weiß jeder brot und so
der wahlleute man es tut mir wirklich
sehr leid dass ich ja schon wieder
meckere ich weiß auch dass ich bei
vielen essens videos rummeckern aber für
filme hier auf das fleisch das ist doch
hätte sicher schlimmer aus als bei einem
cheeseburger das ist jetzt sehr baking
supreme berger irgendwie so gut
probieren wir erstmal die pommes
brutaler frisch also wirklich selten
schlechte pommes gegessen habe auch
irgendwie so ganz komischen neben
geschmack als wäre die friteuse in der
zubereitet wurden schon länger nicht
mehr
dann hoffe ich mal trotzdem noch hier
eben die schäden so war das glaube ich
das mal geil mit frühlingsrollen konnte
ich mir hier gebaut und verkauft also so
sind beide absolut in ordnung wobei die
wahrscheinlich nicht selber gemacht
wurden ist klar und die pommes reinfall
also nicht so nice und jetzt passt auf
ich schneide im burger ist einfach meine
mitte durch okay das sieht man auch
schon an fleisch und zwar ist das
natürlich sehr durch und es ist vor
allem auch so tiefkühlwaren was halt
schon ein bisschen länger unterwegs ist
das ist anders als bei guten bürger
leben die heimische qualität haben
also ich weiß noch letztens habe ich
manchmal irgendwie in dänemark da habe
ich auch in so einem burger ladenburger
bestellt er sah genauso aus und da habe
ich auch wieder leute wen wollt ihr
eigentlich verarschen okay aber ich
probiere es natürlich trotzdem kann ja
sein dass es gut schmeckt also der
geruch ist gut und dann auge ist aber
auch mit und das ist nicht so
wobei der geschmack der geht eigentlich
finde ich jetzt
es ist schwierig also ich hätte ich
hatte gedacht also das schlimmer
ok müsste ich es punkte geben würde ich
den burger sogar sechs von zehn der 15
15 was eigentlich sogar aber ganz gutes
der ist gehört auf jeden fall erst zu
den schlechteren daran nicht gegessen
hat allerdings auch ich zu dem
kompletten schrott also da ist
geschmacklich ein bisschen besser
trotzdem muss man halt irgendwie sagen
ich frage mich welche leute sich so die
ideen kopf setzen lassen wir so einen
burger lieferdienst machen bei
lieferando und dann solche zutaten
bereit stellen zu meistern
also es ist halt alles aus dem
supermarkt wir gehen wahrscheinlich
morgens einkaufen machen das dann fällig
oder nix raus an der kunden wer auch
immer dafür stellt ich hatte noch
vorgeschlagen drei sterne essen
lieferungen war in ordnung berichtete 55
minuten vier sterne
dann ist das nämlich die erste bewertung
ja leute ich bin mal gespannt wir
verfolgen das natürlich ein bisschen
auch dieser lagen lange bestehen bleibt
war die soße ist richtig ist was mir
gerade aber auch noch eingefallen ist
ich habe vor einem jahr ungefähr mal so
den schlechtesten bürgerladen in köln
getestet der hatte 1,3 sterne bei google
das war so eine hinterhof wird es nach
pisse gestanden und den burger den die
gemacht haben der ähnlich geschmeckt
also weißt du wie ich mein ich habe doch
immer so ein bisschen komisches gefühl
wenn die dannenberger liefern und das
nun lieferdienstes was halt die hygiene
und so ich will jetzt wahrscheinlich
schon jetzt in den kommentaren dass ich
in der rolle soll becker kann ich auch
verstehen heute aber tut mir leid das
ist meine meinung dazu
drei sterne fürs essen vier sterne für
die lieferung das reicht da jetzt haben
wir die erste bewertung ich habe mir das
video hat euch halbwegs gefallen und so
weiter neue restaurants kommen mit null
sterne bewertungen dann werden natürlich
auch nicht mehr getestet die post in
kombination mit dieser soße und dann
noch ein bisschen ein kleines stück vom
burger ist eigentlich kann man essen
das war's wir sehen uns morgen wieder
haut rein